[Music]
my life is all over the place I was
broke okay with me
no girl that we got stable back in over
I can't you let other people prop you up
it's gotta do [ __ ] for yourself I'm
about to throw a block party
you'll need a farmer in chat to some of
the extra TVP but I am on my way to the
Asian one just sometimes people can
surprise you like they think how do you
know in Israel it feels pretty real to
me
[Music]
I'm just gonna get more responsible
I thank to park Ted I could still drop
it left you just got to help me up
though
he's really better ever since I got
pregnant just feel so left out
everything's different now we don't have
to be and we'll always be friends yeah
[Music]
morons
what have you been up to 32 years old
can't keep doing this [ __ ] Lawrence
would you take easy back hell nah I
should probably go say hi to my eyes
good to see you again
Lauren I think over him Nathan better
know how lucky you
Nathan hasn't been picking up baby back
in a minute
what are y'all doing out here why won't
we learn your planning committee Claire
asked to do it and she's a mother so I
just thought she'd be helpful because I
don't have a baby I couldn't do that for
me a spa party I just wish we could get
like a really big headliner
what do you mean wish we are thank you
for meeting us with me do you need to
look no I'm good actually I have a date
I thought maybe I scared you away when I
told you I was divorced showed up at
your house and I said it's a son with
the quickness
you should let myself like how you
handle going over his house you came
after me and then he just left
I'm not sure now oh good Bagginses some
time to figure out what I want
you
you